なんかなぁ、エプロンみたいなの
あったらいいんだけどな〜
エプロン持ってないんだよな
流石にエプロンはないよね
えーエプロンでも着けたい
エプロン探す✩
あぁ！あった！あったぞ！
こんにちは！「シェフ」はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんこれ食べましたでしょうか？
私はこれを食べた瞬間思いました
これに～僕はちょっと可能性を感じました
これ中見てもらえば分かるんですけども、
中は普通の麺なんですよ
中は普通の麺なんで、
ソースだけがチョコレート
このソースによってこの麺が～
焼きそばの麺がチョコレートになるという仕組みになっております
つまりこの麺自体には全くこのチョコレートと関係がない
ペヤング焼きそばのチョコレート味食べた時に、
結構割とイケると思ったんですよ
とぅまりこの麺が凄い
ソースかけても美味しくなる麺が凄い
ひょっとしたらこの麺が万能なんじゃないかと思いまして
僕今回この麺を使って、
あつぁぁぁぁあい！！！
チョコレートを混ぜても合うということは
この麺が凄いんですよ、むしろ
なんで僕はそこに着目してぇ
今回はこのペヤング焼きそばの麺を使って、
僕の大好きなチーズケーキ味のペヤング焼きそばを作れれば良いなと思います。
ってかなんとしても作ります。
用意するものは簡単さ、
花畑牧場のチーズタルト
(mgmg・・・
( 美　味　い　や　な　い　か　い )
シュークリーム
あとニューヨークチーズケーキ
あとは本物のチーズ
カマンベールチーズスフレを使います。
この五つを上手いこと麺に絡ませて、
シュークリームの中のクリームがたぶんこのソースの役割をすると思います。
いやぁちょっと
本気でマジで美味しいの作りに行こうと思います今日は。
無限の可能性ですよ！？
僕、あの・・・ペヤング焼きそばのチョコレート味、
ぶっちゃけ言うとたぶん、
よーしちょっと本気で作ります今日は。
わぁぁ！！！　おぉぉ！！！
おいっ！！　わいっ！！　わぃたぁぁ！！！
わぁ・・・　危ない・・・((小声
ふうぅぅぅ！(安堵
チーズケーキ味のペヤング焼きそば・・・
少々お待ちを。
パチンッ☆((指を鳴らす音
はい！では作っていきまーす。
まずは、この普通の麺に、いかにチーズ感を出していくか・・・
まぁ、それが今回の目標ですね。
ひとまず、チーズタルトぶち込みます
バンッ
あっ。かたいなぁ。
ちょっとチーズタルト一回やめよう。
まずは、ニューヨークチーズケーキを入れましょう。
細かく砕きます。
ゥオらぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁい！！！
わぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！
ついでにチーズタルトも砕いてしまいましょう。
ドゴォ
今回の目標は麺に絡ませることなので、
ひとまず、これでかなりチーズ感は出るのではないでしょうか
バッチリです！
これを混ぜていきましょう。
あ～かなりイイ感じになったのではないでしょうか。
…んーちょっとズームはきつい(￣▽￣;)
で、この後ですね。これに、
チーズを溶かしてつけていきます。
２ピース使います。
２つ出して
シュパッ  シュパッ　ドグシャァァ
やかんの底を使って溶かしていきます。
まぁ、チーズはご存知の通り熱で溶けるので、
まぁ、チーズフォンデュみたいな感じですね。
チーズを溶かしていきます。
全然溶けねえわ・・・
全然溶けねえじゃん！！！！
なんで？チーズフォンデュってこうやったら溶けるって、
なんか見たことあるよ？俺、チーズフォンデュのやつで。
トロトロってなると思ったら、ドゥワァってなっちゃってるね。
いよいよラストでございます。
シュークリームの中のクリームを使います。
これはねぇ、悪くない判断だと思うよ？
チーズケーキっつってもやっぱねぇ、クリームが大事な部分あるんで、
あぁ＾～いいでスね＾～
う～ん、良いんじゃなぁい？
ふぁいごにヴぉれうぉまヴぇあわせふぇdrftgy(口にものを入れながら
あっ、なんか―
ウマそうに見えてきたぞ？
はい！って言うわけで完成しました。
チーズケーキ味のペヤング焼きそばです。
いや～悪くないッスよこれ！たぶん
もう焼きそばって概念じゃないんですよ
あの～、焼きそばの人たちがふざける、
あの～ショートケーキ味とか、チョコ味とかあるじゃないですか。
まぁ、焼きそばなんですけど、あれはもう、
ごはんではなくもうスイーツとして見ている焼きそばだと思います。
まぁ、その定義にのっとって今回はこのチーズケーキ味を作ったんですけども、
まぁ、基本的にはそのギミックは変わってないのかなと思います。
まぁ、焼きそばと言うね、その味をペーストしやすい素材に基づいて
僕なりにそのチーズケーキの良さ、クリーミー感をしっかり引き立てた上で
チーズケーキ味をしっかり味付けできたのかと思っております！
問題は味の方です！
これで美味しければもうホント商品化、も～～～ペヤングさん・・・
いただきます。
え～。マジか・・・
ある！ある！！ある！！！
食べれる！全然食べれる！
全然悪くはないです
ウン、結論から言うと全然食べれる
イヤこれ美味いんじゃないかぁ！？
なんか、本当にちゃんとチーズの味はするよ。
美味しいチーズケーキの焼きそばになっていますが、
まぁ、欲を言うと
焼　き　そ　ば　は　抜　い　た　方　が　良　い